je sais pas c'est peut-être un point où
il ya plus de monde que pas lorsqu'on
trouve une salle de vaccination en
arrivant au zoo de thoiry
on est en droit de se poser la question
depuis leucate aude visiteurs et
riverains peuvent venir s'y faire
vacciner on s'est dit ok on peut on peut
juste mettre un antigénique ou un pcr
éventuellement sur le parc mais aussi on
peut offrir la possibilité aux riverains
et à tout le monde et que ce soit ouvert
à tout le monde et profiter justement
d'une visite aux oraux peut-être pour
sensibiliser aussi les enfants les gens
à ce vaccin pour qu'on puisse sortir un
petit peu le plus rapidement le ciel
crise qu'on connaît depuis deux ans en
trois jours d'ouverture plus d'une
centaine de personnes ont déjà reçu leur
piqûre
on a rempli une petite feuille et puis
on nous a pris tout de suite les dames a
été très gentille tout s'est bien passé
mais qu'on a vu que c'était sûr touahri
on n'a pas hésité tout le monde connaît
touahri puis ça permet aussi pour les
gens qui connaissent peut-être pas de
devenir un peu sur la région et
découvrir ce très beau parc d'ailleurs
n'avait pas prévu autant donc c'est
plutôt une très bonne chose on trouve
très satisfait on a plus de demandes de
plus d'offres donc on va essayer
d'augmenter notre enfant ouvert à
l'origine de 10 heures à 13 heures le
planning quotidien c'est déjà élargie
jusqu'à 15 heures une première semaine
rassurante qui conforte la mise en place
du projet le projet ce serait de
développer le sur le site plusieurs
postes de vaccination accessible à la
population générale et avec ou sans
rendez-vous est aussi accessible aux
clients du parken qui pourraient saint
maxin et en entrant ou sortant depuis
l'instauration du pass vaccinale à
l'entrée du zoo la fréquentation a
baissé de 30% à thoiry pourtant même
sens on passe le forfait safari only a
été rétabli pour pouvoir observer les
animaux de sa voiture